you're a socialist i when it comes to
women's issues i'm assuming yes when it
comes to
women's bodies i'm a socialist trying to
seize the means of reproduction let's go
baby i see you that was the next level
joke thank you seize the means of
reproduction now technically that would
make me a conservative though why
because you're trying to grab them
no
conservatives are trying to seize the
means of reproduction why are you being
so communist what do you mean well
you're trying to seize the means of
reproduction yeah wow
i'd be a smart spin but they wouldn't
get it because i'm barely getting it
mark can you explain it with your gay
things
miles
pro-life terrier
oh that was good that was good look at
us we're firing on all
cylinders right now